for a while there it seemed like
everyone wanted me to play an agent
a network executive a lawyer i'm not a
duplicitous person i am not running
a con on anyone but for some reason
people felt i
was able to inhabit those roles well
which is uh perfectly fine with me it's
all pretend
[Music]
i just got a phone call from my agent
and he said
there's a show called breaking bad
they're going to invite you to do a part
you've got to say yes to this one this
is the kind of part
people win emmys for well i haven't won
an emmy yet but i've come close
so my agent was pretty on the nose there
he he knew what he was talking about
anyway i'd never seen breaking bad it
was in its second
season and it was not doing well in the
ratings
didn't really do well until the third
and fourth seasons
i called a friend as soon as my agent
hung up and i said have you ever heard
of this show breaking bad and he said
it's the best show on tv you have to say
yes to that
whatever they ask you to do say yes so
vince calls and he goes there's a
character he's named saul goodman he's
got he's a lawyer he's a sleazy lawyer
you see these guys on the back of buses
they have the little advertisement on
the back of the bus i said i know we
barely know each other
i've not read anything but i have an
idea for his hair
i said can he have a comb over and a
mullet
and then clean on the sides and vince
goes yeah
i think that'd work that sounds pretty
good what you two need is an
honest-to-god
businessman right somebody who treats
your product like the simple high margin
commodity
that it is somebody who ships out of
town deals only in bulk
someone who's been doing this for 20
years
and never been caught the look of saul
is a big
part of how i play them and where i draw
the energy from
i've always gotten a lot from hair and
facial hair
and costume as far as informing and
telling me who this person is and how
they
how they walk and sit and stand and talk
you know the part was written by peter
gould
who then carried on to crete better call
saul with
vince gilligan and who now runs that
show for the last few years
those guys just were really having fun
and in fact they gave me the part not
because of larry sanders which is what i
thought
they gave me the part because of mr show
so
give them tons of credit for foresight
[Music]
it's uh the biggest best role i probably
ever have in my life
they don't there's there's almost no
role
you can point to that has as much humor
comedy
pure comedy in a scene and then two
scenes later
drama directness simplicity and
earnestness
all those things right near each other
and all of them tied together and
grounded i've never
done anything to deserve the range of
that role
there's great actors and people training
at juilliard right now who
will never get a role that good in their
lives
so i treasure it and i want to make the
most of it and i don't know how it ends
i kind of hope that the character of
jimmy mcgill finds some
way to be at peace with the world and
feel
uh valued and loved but i have a feeling
that's not what's gonna happen you know
what um
i think tomorrow i might uh
call that shrink
couldn't hurt right
we didn't have to torture ourselves to
invent jimmy because
saul goodman in breaking bad you only
ever see him at work
so because of that there's nothing
established about his personal life
and there was nothing that had to be
understood or explained he's very much a
facade
that gave vince gilligan and peter gould
and all the other writers a great degree
of freedom
to invent jimmy mcgill and we all agreed
that the first thing they needed to do
was make him
likable someone that you would root for
because as fun as saul goodman was in
breaking bad he was only fun
and funny in relation to a group of
people who
all had guns to their heads and were
torturing each other and the two of you
agreed that since
as everybody knows you're going back to
work any day now that the firm
should help you make ends meet that's
correct minus the sarcasm
hamlet's making you a jump i'm going to
get better
they really did a beautiful thing in
inventing jimmy mcgill
and giving him that back story and his
brother who he's caring for played by
michael mckean and
ray seahorn playing kim wexler someone
he loves
they really built someone that you could
uh
you could like
[Music]
mr show was my dream come true i met
robert smeigle
and through robert and working with him
i got hired at saturday night live and
worked there for a couple years
and i went to la and i was doing my own
thing
and i got hired at the ben stiller show
which was a wonderful place to work and
we had so much fun but it was
very short-lived and then i met david
cross
for the second or third or fifth time i
didn't really talk to him the first
couple times i met him
and i realized we were on the same
wavelength comedically and we started
writing together and we clicked
immediately
we did sketches here in town and
started pitching a show that would be
like monty python in that
one sketch would sort of transform into
the next sketch
and we would be political but not on the
nose not
topical but we would be socially
political and aware
and very very silly and hopefully a
little bit smart
and hopefully very very funny i wrote it
down in case you wanted it
why would i want that old thing when i
can have this
[Music]
and that was mr show and hbo picked it
up and we did it for
four years we did 33 episodes
uh they're jam-packed with jokes and
laughs and
funny characters and ideas just it's my
brain on screen
so if you want to know what it's like
inside this mad house
you go watch mr show don't worry mother
the wind
[Laughter]
you did it twice three times
you weren't here
i thought i have this kind of intensity
inside me that
i've occasionally showed and
occasionally for comedy sake in mr show
people loved when i would scream god
damn it
god damn it god damn it greg god damn it
get out
of there and we often used it for laughs
i uh
asked around to the powers that be in
hollywood and
people kind of liked the idea they
thought there was something to it a kind
of more of an everyman
action hero somebody who looks really
not like
he's gonna kick your ass
[Music]
i'm playing this character hutch mansell
who's a father a dad and has a real
nothing job he's hidden away he's
purposefully hidden
himself away some incidents happen that
bring out the beast inside him and i get
to
rage full-on in action hero mode do some
amazing screen fighting which i trained
for two years for
and i'm very proud to say i did all my
own fighting
and i loved it
my favorite thing to shoot in nobody was
the bus fight it was an opportunity for
me to show what i'd learned
of training for two years i got out a
lot of rage
i got to laugh a lot it was very
inventive physical fighting there was
all these people involved and we had to
work together to shoot it was a group
effort
greg ramenter uh was the director on
that sequence
ilya nyschuler directed the movie and my
good friend
daniel bernhardt who trained me for two
damn years of patience and fortitude
was in it as well and so i got to make
that
fight sequence with my friends and make
a fight sequence that i'm really proud
of
larry called me and asked me to play a
a porn and ex-porn star he told me
there's gonna be a dinner party at your
house
and you're gonna tell a really crude
story from your porn days and you need
to write
two porn stories that are really
inappropriate
you guys looking around it's a great
house great place my wife
jokingly refers to it as the house that
built
because of my porn i never made enough
money to buy it
i told her he wrote the line when i
welcome him to my house
that's larry david so much fun to
improvise
comedy that way in a kind of a subtle
and
you know realist kind of vibe a great
experience
to do curvier enthusiasm and i've always
wanted to do
more like it and there aren't many shows
that shoot that way
but it's usually a small personal
idiosyncrasy
that you're told to lead the way and
then you just
everything else is a riff
[Music]
i was a writer and performer on the ben
stiller show which was a sketch show on
fox tv that ran for
12 beautiful episodes gary
was a guest on our show we all had a
good time talking to him
but then he had his show and he needed
someone to play his agent he clearly
wanted a young person
and gary did this very nice thing of
calling me aside and talking to me about
the role
and uh i got it i signed barry levinson
last week
just came by to hold his hand say listen
if you guys need any help booking guests
just pick up the phone
is a fast talking agent not unlike
saul goodman uh certainly the one we met
in breaking bad
but this was years before that and it
was based
on my agent at the time ari emanuel very
famous agent who
later was also built into a character on
entourage
played by jeremy piven i think jeremy
probably
nailed him a little better than i did
but i just was using
this kind of energy that i got from my
friend ari emanuel or he's a very
energetic guy
to the point where he is almost so
carried away with his ideas that he'll
phone you and then he won't listen to
you
because he's already moved on it's kind
of rude but
i never minded it i just liked him i
liked his energy
for a while there it seemed like
everyone wanted me to play an agent
a network executive a lawyer i'm not a
duplicitous person i i'm not running a
con
on anyone but for some reason people
felt i
was able to inhabit those roles well
which is uh perfectly fine with me it's
all pretend
so larry are we uh on
yeah yeah boom you're number one yeah i
love
working with gary shandling he was the
mastermind of that show
it was a unique show i'd never seen
comedy that was
as dry and subtle as what gary pulled
off
on the larry sanders show i loved him
i'm so proud to be a part of it working
with bruce stern was a
treasured memory for me maybe we'll get
to work together again
he's so great and of course i love will
forte because he's a sweetheart
at one point i had to read a news report
it was just
dry factual nothingness and
i literally couldn't make it through
this stupid simple thing
so i said to alexander i said can i just
do a comedy version of this just one
time
just roll the cameras and i'm just gonna
make fun of every one of these stories
and he said sure i went through and
every story i just made fun of
i made i made a joke about and i got
that out of me
and then i was able to be a real actor
the council is expected to debate the
proposal
in monday's session coming up next in
sports carter
brings us the story of a hardened
snowmobiler who may have lost his legs
but not
his will to compete
i was just offered that role on seinfeld
and it was a great experience you know
seinfeld worked like a
laugh machine and not in a bad way
not in a cold and unfeeling and
mechanical way but
in a reliable and professional way
so i went in acted it
didn't have to exaggerate the person
just played him earnestly
it was a great great experience you know
i'm not really a doctor
oh i'm not really attracted to you
well i'm seriously and i went to medical
school but i still have to pass my
licensing exam
they were such a team on the same page
working together so well uh that you
just
tried to catch up and and just say your
lines at the right time and everything
would be okay
i did not watch seinfeld until after it
was
long over my girlfriend at the time was
a huge fan
so i certainly knew that it was great
but the last time i'd really seen larry
david was
at the improv in new york when i was a
writer for saturday night live
and he was totally out of work i'm not
sure if he was penniless
but just it's fun to imagine a penniless
larry david
he complained even more than he does now
that he's a billionaire
now that i've watched every single
episode
it is in my top three sitcoms of all
time